my name is Vaughn and I am Alive my name
is essence and I am Alive my name is
Vickie and I'm alive should I say that
more lively
my name is Augusta and I am alive I'm
alive yes I am yep I'm alive I am most
certainly alive why am I here where was
I when I found out Blake Shelton was the
sexiest man alive I was on the New
Jersey Transit I was sitting in a chair
a nice chair just relaxing in a chair
yeah who gives a [ __ ]
is he really dead s I'm not kidding
it's like Sheldon really the sexiest man
alive to say I was outraged
would be an understatement go Blake this
is your time this is your moment when I
first heard about it I thought people
were saying he was the most sexist a man
alive and I was like damn [ __ ] up but
Hollywood and then I read that it was
most sexiest man alive and I was sure at
first I was like how did this guy get
voted the most sexiest man alive and
then I was like hey if he can do it
maybe 2018 is my hair I see where the
committee was coming from actually no I
don't really see where the committee was
coming from to be honest with you
is he really I feel like honestly people
named Blake have been getting called
sexy too much across all of history why
is this a video I just like for so long
Blake has been kind of this like
underdog within country
underdog in terms of popularity but in
terms of sex appeal so out of like all
the men Blake Shelton is the sexiest man
alive like what about Pharrell I mean a
Hemsworth or something Jake Gyllenhaal
Mercker shelah Ali that guy from
moonlight honestly any one of the five
in the more action there just Elba
and grow justin theroux the ryan's ryan
gosling Ryan Reynolds Ryan Gosling Billy
Ray Cyrus over Blake Sheldon McFee Jeff
Goldblum my mailman Ralph a firefighter
why do care I am Alive and I was not a
part of this decision-making process at
all no one consulted me I didn't get a
phone call I didn't get an email who
makes those lists this has white male
written all over it gotta be Russia wait
people are upset about this I feel like
we have a few more things to be upset
about these days here's the sexiest what
you find sexy right here and that's some
really nice pecs are very sexy and also
your heart I guess but the actual heart
isn't actually sexy if you've ever seen
a heart it's gross man congratulations
Blake I know you really didn't do
anything for this besides exist but good
job I guess
as they say chew tobacco chew tobacco
chew tobacco spit and as Jake Paul says
dab on them haters
[Music]